[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where
it's my job to interview
people who are the best at what they do
or certainly world-class performers my
guest today is sydney native we're going
to talk about sydney
jim jeffries jim is one of the most
popular and respected comedians of his
generation entertaining audiences
including yours truly
around the globe with his provocative
belief-challenging and thought-provoking
comedy i would underscore the
thought-provoking he created and starred
in the sitcom legit
in the comedy central late night show
the jim jeffries show jim was honored as
stand-up comedian of the year at the
just for last festival in summer 2019
at the end of 2019 he embarked on his
new tour oblivious
touring all around europe and north
america he is currently working with
nbc on a multi-camera pilot which he
will star in from writer producer
suzanne martin
sean hayes and todd milliner's hazy
mills and universal tv
his new podcast i don't know about that
debuts
on tuesday may 5th you should check it
out and his ninth
count them nine that's incredible stand
up special will be released later this
year on netflix you can find them on all
the socials
at jim jeffries that's j
j-e-f-f-e-r-i-e-s
and jim jeffries.com jim welcome to the
show
thanks for having me tim that's it tim
ferriss it's a very good australian name
i'm sure you get that a lot right i do i
do yeah
you know like the guitarist from in
excess you obviously know that right
that's exactly right yeah
i have i have a tim ferriss story let's
hear it
i i was performing at the end more
theater in
in um sydney and tim farris came
backstage at my gig and i was like a
kid from australia very excited to me
the guitar is from nxs and i think he
wrote most of the songs as well you know
and um and when i when i saw him he just
had like his finger had
fallen off like it'd been like i think
it was a boating accident or something
his finger had been ripped off and i was
like wow
so he goes yeah that's the end in excess
i can't really play guitar anymore
because i can't you know
play the chords because i don't have
this finger anymore and i went that's a
shame
and so you know i said to him i said so
it turns out your finger was more vital
than michael hutchins
because you know in excess i think had
three new singers and they kept going
but
you lose tim ferriss finger and they
can't play anymore
well that is the first separate tim
ferriss anecdote that has ever happened
in 400 plus episodes so i'm thrilled you
know i've i've had that name pop up
before
the comparison but i've never heard an
actual story so that's
he's a very he's a very nice man it was
the faris brothers they all went to the
there was my school and then there was
the school next to us
and we had a rivalry with him and our
school was like oh we beat you in rugby
and they're like
we we had in excess and we were like oh
you win
yeah that's uh like the most famous
person to come from my school i think is
me you know what i mean like we haven't
got a great track record
so hello to all the people at sinai's
high in sydney that's where i went but
uh yeah
we had me i think a couple of people who
got like bronze in the olympics and some
relief picture for
the angels back in the 90s well let's
let's talk about sydney i have
actually spent a fair amount of time
there i've rented an apartment with a
friend in willamaloo
and that's that's a bit of money that's
where the prime minister lives
well you know it was uh it was it was
his idea
although i will tell you the drawback
and you can probably tell me what these
birds are you have the most beautiful
white birds that make the most god-awful
sounds
oh australian women yeah yeah
[Applause]
i don't know what you're talking about
good looking but the accent's [ __ ]
horrendous
yeah you know i've met them in my day oh
yeah i'm enjoying that
keep doing it oh yeah that feels good
yeah i know the worst worst accent for
sex in the world is the australian
female
but what bird are you talking about
there's some protected bird i want to
say maybe it's a macaw
it's this white bird that has this plume
on its head and it's oh it's
it's it's it's a gala that's a oh no a
cockatoo cockatoo
yeah a cockatoo okay i tell you my
father
has okay my father's like he's like
this guy that he's one with animals for
whatever reason
and he has this like our veranda he
opens up the doors and each day these
two
rainbow lorikeets come and visit my
father and they fly in the window and
they just sit on his shoulders now
cockatoos look very
exotic here in america but they're
everywhere in australia they're not
endangered at all they're all
my dad thinks they're a pest right and
he goes there's a cockatoo that bothers
those two rainbow lorikeets so my father
keeps a slingshot and some rocks
by the side of his chair
and he shoots the cockatoos and they
come over and and my friend my american
friend who co-hosts my podcast with me
forrest was there and he goes
he goes does it kill him he goes ah no
he just gives him a bit of a scare
you know if he hit one of them in the
eye you know why were you in sydney for
so long were you just uh backpacking or
i was there because my one of my best
friends is actually kiwi
was living in sydney at the time and he
invited me to head over
and separately the australian edition of
my first book
was launching in sydney and they wanted
me to
show up for a handful of media gigs and
this that and the other thing and so i
combined everything together and stayed
for
two two and a half weeks it probably
only took me two two and a half minutes
to get
my pale scalp annihilated by your
yeah ozone free sun
people don't know that there's two holes
in the ozone layer and one's over i
think i think the north the north pole
i think or it might be the south and the
other holes over australia and australia
when when you watch like um
okay so when you watch the weather here
in america it'll go and the temperature
is going to be this the humidity is
going to be this and there's some winds
coming in from over here
but you never get the the daily uv
rating
where in australia and they go and it's
100 uv today and it's like a hundred
percent
is like normal thing so it's like it's
like you don't even really think about
skin cancer that much in america like
you know it happens and you have to be
wary of it and if you have a mole you
get it checked and that type of stuff
but skin cancer if it's not number one
it's very close to the number one cancer
in australia
and so we had a slogan when i was a kid
called slip slop slap
and it was slip on a shirt slap on
sunscreen and slap on a hat
and that's how you what you have to do
if you want to go outdoors and now the
kids today
in australia if you're at school they
have a policy called no hat no play
you can't go out of the classroom if
you're not wearing a hat and the hat
will have like one of those things down
the back
so it covers your neck as well it's a
good look
well if you go to bandai maybe not
bandai i'm not sure where the best
surfing beaches are but if you go to
some of these beaches
i was astonished because i saw all the
surfers look like they were getting
ready for an
antarctic expedition i mean they had the
ear flaps the neck flaps
they had enough zinc on their face to to
make them look like snowmen
oh yeah we always had like fluorescent
zinc on our noses as kids in the 80s and
now they still just put the white stuff
but that was how you sort of
showed how uh your personality whether
you had pink or green or fluoro
yellow or whatever like that but it i
like to look at like bondi beach
and just watch the british people who
have never seen sun
just like and you know they've been
there for a week going go on there
lay out enjoy yourself they're all just
getting burnt the [ __ ]
yeah that's what we love watching the
british get burnt in australia
well i suppose bandai if i remember
correctly because my
my friend used to be a lifeguard
actually and he was saying you could
just sit at a cafe
and you could watch i suppose on one
hand the brits just get
turned into rotisserie chicken and then
you could see tourists
from uh he said in particular from china
just gets
swept out to sea because they were the
rips
yeah yeah yeah yeah i i i mind you
when i was a kid that happened to me a
few times when you swim out a bit far
and then you start drifting off and
you're like ah
[ __ ] i'm gonna die i did that thing
where i waved and then like someone has
to come out a little boat
and come and get you and you're like
sorry about that or i swam a bit far
you know so to this day i don't go far
out in the ocean yeah
when did you feel confident
in comedy as your direction actually
before we get to that let's bookmark
that question i just want to say
something before i forget
and not to get all sentimental this
early on our first date but
i owe you a debt of gratitude because
your comedy has helped me get through
some really dark periods and that might
sound funny because your comedy itself
can be dark at points but
putting that aside uh i've really
enjoyed your comedy over the years
and it's been not just entertaining but
really helpful
to me at points so thank you for that oh
no problem that's very sweet thing of
you to say
and uh so to comedy and direction when
did you
when did you feel confident that that
was your i wanted to be a comedian
from the age of about 13 14
you know um and then i
i i did it two times three times when i
was 17
and one time i did it and it went really
well
and the it was the comedy store in
sydney and you have to go down there and
they put your name in a hat and they
pull your name out and
i had five minutes and it was just all
about being in school or whatever i
can't even remember what i talked about
and um then they said oh you're not 18
are you and i was like no
and they go you have to come back with a
parent and so i hadn't told my parents
and my parents says well i hadn't even
told them that i went into the city
like i wasn't allowed to go into the
city you know i lived out in the suburbs
and i told them i went to a mate's house
or something so i traveled into the city
and um so so next time me dad had to
come with me and i remember it was like
bucketing down with rain
and i went out there and i got back on
and the only other people in the
audience because it was raining were the
other comedians waiting to go on and
there was the
the full range of people who were
getting good at it people who
were never going to get good at it and
people who their first go and people
have been trying for years and
anyway i gotta i couldn't have had a
worse gig i couldn't have died
worse than that and i i got in the car
with me dad afterwards and me dad said
he goes oh you're a good kid and you've
got a lot of good qualities but uh
but this isn't for you and uh my heart
sank and i then i went and did it one
more time just to see
because that first time went so well and
then i did it again and i died again
and i went all right this isn't for me
and then i didn't go up again until i
was 20.
i didn't do it yeah i waited another
three years i
i used to think it was more than that
but i was in college and i
used to run my own comedy night and i
remember there was a
there was a i was in perth when i
started doing that so a lot of people
think i'm from perth because of this
because i really started doing comedy in
perth but
um i i i the the way that a lot of
people get stage time is what you do is
you find a venue you put your own
shows on you book your own comedians and
that way you can mc and you can get
better by
you know because i couldn't get gig so i
thought i'd run my own gig
and there was there was this area in
perth called claremont
and claremont um had a
a serial killer at the time the clan
had the claire had the claremont killer
right so what happened
i don't think they ever caught him i
don't know but maybe they did catch him
i don't know but when i was there
the guy called the claremont killer and
what happened was with the claremont
killer
all the all the bars that were normally
this is a big party area of perth
they were all no one was going out
because all the girls who got killed
the last thing that happened for them
they left the nightclub and got into a
taxi or went looking for a taxi
and then they were never seen again so
that nightlife there just died so there
was all these
like bars that were just empty and so i
went into one like oh can i have a gig
like that and they were just happy to
have anyone in the building
and i used to get like 15 people me
mates to come along to these shows and
it was like a really popular bar but on
a friday night i could have a gig there
because of the killer so
you know silver lining to what happened
there
and when you if we go back to 17 you
tried it three times
maybe this isn't for me what in your
head was plan b
or the alternative well there's a weird
thing that sort of i think there's a
you know for people who really know
about me and there's not many people but
there's there's a bit of a myth about me
being an opera singer
which is is vaguely true right
what happened was when i was 17 i was in
a school musical
and then i was doing a write and then
someone said oh you should get some
singing lessons and blah blah blah and
so i got some singing lessons with this
guy
called richard gill who has since passed
and he was one of the main conductors
for the sydney opera and he
he um he got me he
he got me a part in the chorus of of uh
wagner's the flying dutchman and i had
to sing in german i was like 17 and i
just
sang i just i just bought a cd of this
this opera and i just mimicked it you
know
and i i wasn't that great a singer but
after that i i i um i got into
uh wapo which is the west australian
academy of performing arts
and i studied musical theater and then i
studied opera in the next year and so
so i i was a professional opera singer
for a few weeks
of my life but it was never it was never
a full-blown thing but
i did this course it was the same course
that hugh jackman did
and it was like a it was a full
scholarship ride and i remember because
i didn't have the marks
in school to get into anything academic
in university and
i i don't believe i had the marks to
actually get into this course but they
never checked my for my high school
certificate
and i just um went in and did a dance
and singing audition and stuff and i
always still wanted to be a comic but
because i thought the comedy wouldn't
work out i still wanted to be an
entertainer and a performer so i thought
ah this is another thing i can do and it
was also i think for my mother at that
stage
that was something that she was far
happier
to brag about that i was studying music
in a prestigious college or something
like that but on
maybe my second year into the course
there was a comedian called gary who
who was like this guy who'd been on
australian tv i'm still i still know
gary this day he's very nice man
and uh he'd come over to do a gig in
perth and i was his opening act and we
had we had a few drinks afterwards we
got along i think he liked me more as a
person than he liked me as a comic but
he said
he said do you want to come and do these
these uh mining
town gigs and i thought i thought ah
that's too good an opportunity so i quit
university and i went out to like places
like kalgoorlie
and these little gold mining towns and i
performed in these bars just to like
australian cowboys pretty much like guys
in cowboy hats they
live out in the land and they work in
the mines and all that type of stuff
these towns had so many men
working out there and so few women that
in the bars in these towns the bartender
would be a female and b
and they'd ship them in and they'd call
them skimpy's
and a skimpy and she would just be
topless now
this wasn't this wasn't um a strip bar
this was just a normal bar all the bars
have topless bartenders
in all these um little country towns and
the reason for that
is if you take away the topless girl
behind the bar
it's a gaber it's just
it's just it's just men so so they had
to go no no no
we're not gay because they all dressed
like cowboys just on this thing no we're
not gay there's a pair of tits over
there so we're all right you know
and so i did these gigs and i thought i
had i hadn't told my parents
that i'd quit university i thought you
know
i thought i'll just keep doing this
until i can be a full-time comic and
then i think
it's basically the storyline of the
movie punchline that
tom hanks character who said he said oh
no i'm going to be a doctor i'm going to
be a doctor and then
he said he'd tell his parents once he's
a professional coming
but then i just quit uni i went back to
sydney
to my parents and said i'm going to give
stand-up comedy a go
and then i think i moved to england i
moved to england then
um i know the day i moved to england
because i was packing my suitcase
and at about 10 o'clock at night and i
was all excited it was gonna be my first
time traveling overseas i'd never been i
know i
tell a lie i've been to america once
when i was 14. but it was my first time
traveling overseas by myself without
family members yeah and i was going on
me big adventure by myself i was getting
on a plane and uh
and uh i was packing me bags and the and
the twin towers fell down
and that's when that's how i that's how
i can remember the date that i left for
britain
the next day yeah yeah now you leaving
to britain
i had read trying to do homework for
this conversation
there you'd commented somewhere that
there were
lots of funny comics in australia some
people funnier than you
but you had more ambition than some of
them and you ended up going to the uk
you ended up then going to the us
is that is that a misquote i mean you
can't believe everything you read on the
internet i
i think that that's um that's
true but it maybe more ambition is the
wrong way to say it i think
i was in a place in my life
where i was young enough and had less
connections
that i could get up and do that you know
that i didn't have a girlfriend i didn't
have kids you know
and i started pretty early in life at
comedy and a lot of people don't start
till
you know their 30 or their late 20s or
whatever like that and then they
have roots you know and i didn't have
anything holding me back
so there were comics in australia who
were better than me
and um but i feel like maybe they
couldn't get up and go but also
also when i say ambition there's a
difficult thing with australian comedy
because
doing live work in australia is very
difficult because you don't have the
population to sell tickets
people watch comedy australia but
they're going to go out and see the big
acts when they come to town so the
comedy clubs for the most part are empty
and melbourne has
one comedy club sydney i think it has
two uh
perth has one that this isn't enough to
sustain
an industry you know a ground roots
industry anyway and so everybody's
everybody's sort of like when you've
made in australia you're the breakfast
radio guy
if you can get that job and that job in
australia pays really really well
and so everyone's trying to get those
jobs so i think a lot of people
who were good comics maybe had because
no one was really full time maybe had a
good
day job i didn't have a good day job i
was learning f i was selling mobile
phones
during the day when i was a comic in
australia so i
[ __ ] wasn't worried about leaving
that at all
that was i was i was one of the worst
employees a company had ever had and i
worked for a place called stratfield car
radios and i was just
if there was a way to get out of working
i
i had found it there was stairwells that
i hid under and
i did things i did things that seemed
like to get out of work that were more
work than actually doing work you know
if i i had to sell i had to sell car
stereos
and mobile phones and
it was you know i still to this day
if i was to sell a car stereo i wouldn't
know i don't know
how much amplifiers you need to run a
subwoofer
and i sold them for years and i have no
idea
why i was at college i worked for this
guy and i used to just point at things
and guess and go that look at the size
of it and go that'd do it you know
i could i want one time one time i
totaled the guy's
white van like just totaled it just in
in a stereo fitting
which is very what happened was this guy
his white van driver a guy that you know
works a plumber or whatever the [ __ ] he
was you know and he came
in and he goes ah i want some speakers
and a cd player and i was like all right
and i knew which with a good cd player
i got him like a sony cd player and i
said oh this
has enough amps in it that you can run
some six by nine speakers
and i go you just put them in the back
here that's a good size speaker a six by
nine
and that'll be good and then and then he
goes i can only get it today and
all the fitters were full and so i said
uh i
i went down there was a there was a 16
year old apprentice
working down there and i said mate this
is an easy job
just just put the stereo in there and
then i don't know how to [ __ ] do it i
said
and you run the wires along this door
panel down here
and then just whack those speakers in
the side there just into the side wall
and that'll work right now you're meant
to take the panels off
cut the holes in put the speakers in put
the panels back on
but this young fella just got the saw
out and he uh he just started cutting
and it got a bit stiff
anyway he cut out one of the support
beams that support
support the support the roof of the car
and and the
the the the roof of the car just just
slanted down
you know about 45 degrees just sunk into
the thing
and this guy came back to get his car
and i just went
okay well the good news is the stereo
sounds great ah and then just
having i was never felt more terrified
in my life than having to walk this
bloke down just to show him that we
demolished his car in about an hour and
a half
well we the company had insurance for
such
occasions i'm sure i i i i'm sure we
just bought him a new van
there was no way to fix it you can't put
a new support it's not a panel beating
job
we we basically cut the roof off his car
you know so
i assume he got a new van out of it so
he probably did pretty good
you know there was there was a couple of
things like that i saw
i saw a bloke get knocked out uh
changing over
uh i saw a guy they the new bmws and the
european cars had different colored
wires and stuff like that
and he was trying to test the [ __ ]
the the land and the positive and the
negative and the earth and all that type
of stuff
and he's got his test down he's laying
in the front seat of the car
and he touched the wrong wire and was
the wife of the airbag and the airbag
exploded into his head and he was
knocked out and there was just [ __ ]
white dust in a bag
yeah anyway look i'm not saying anything
that's too bad that company's gone bust
now they don't exist anymore so they
can't get angry at me for saying
anything
probably because of [ __ ] me how did
you make the decision
to go to the uk uh why the uk as opposed
to somewhere else is that
is that a usual kind of lily pad for a
lot of promising
australia well the uk has more comedy
clubs
per capita than anywhere in the in the
world far beating
america and also it's just a great place
to do comedy because
it's so compact and you know i remember
i before i moved here to america i used
to [ __ ] and moan about oh i gotta drive
to manchester 200 mile drive
you know what i mean and i used to like
oh i better get a hotel room and stay
the night and all that type of stuff in
america
i'm on planes and flying and driving you
know there's an old saying
that um that americans
think a hundred years is old and british
people think a hundred miles is far
right and i think that sort of sums it
up right
and and uh but also if you're under 27
and you're from the commonwealth and the
people from canada can do this as well
you can get and i think it's one year
now but back then you can get a two-year
work visa
where you're allowed to go out and work
now you're only meant to do menial jobs
you're meant to be bartenders and
whatever
you're not allowed to further your
career
you know so if you walk into any bar in
london it's filled with australian and
new zealand bartenders you know
and um so i had to do comedy on the sly
cash in hand
until till one of the management
companies would give me a work permit
but i i never became a british citizen
or anything i stayed there for 10 years
and my visas would only ever last until
my gigs ran out no one booked you more
than three months in advance so
every three months i went into a panic
like all right i guess it's all over now
this is the end of the career you're
going back to australia and then
i got another one and then i got another
one and i just kept on staying i
i had a girlfriend there for a bit that
i thought i'd marry and thank [ __ ] that
didn't work out you know i look back on
it now but
uh she's a nice enough girl but that
never happened and um
i uh yeah i just kept going and so what
would happen is
in you there was very few american
comics in britain
um i feel like that's different now i
feel like the world of comedy is a lot
more close
it was much more segregated where
everyone was you know
but all the canadians and australians
and uh new zealanders all hung out
together and we all lived in
these houses with like eight comics and
it was good it was probably
i would argue the happiest time in my
life i think that would be the happy and
i was broke as [ __ ] but
you know the the the rise is always
better than the peak man
well let's let's talk about that for a
second so what was it about the rise
that you think was that situation that
contributed to
feeling feeling happy during that period
of time well it was
it was the optimism and also also you
were in it
with a group of you know people who you
all started out with and you were all
supporting each other and it you know
the
the the british scene in my mind is less
competitive than the american scene and
i attribute that to
in america you play a comedy club and
the comedy clubs decide
who's getting paid what and so there's a
real
you're worth this much you're worth this
much you're worth this much
right and so you'll have a headliner who
might be being paid ten thousand dollars
for that show
and you'll have a support act who's
literally getting 40 bucks and that's
still going on right
and so there is a little bit of like
when you're the person earning the 10
000 like don't worry guys i'll i'll get
the drinks
you know what i mean there's a bit of
that but you go
down to i i don't know what it is now
but you go down to the comedy store in
london in the
in the early 2000s 200 pounds a gig for
everybody and you might do two shows
there at night
200 pounds would say like 300 american
bucks or there there abouts you know
and that was a good income that you
could live off
and you know each comic was getting the
same price so you didn't feel like well
why are they getting this and i'm not
getting this in
and if you got famous you got out of the
comedy clubs and you went and did
theaters you never were famous and in
comedy clubs you know and so over
they never the comedy clubs might just
have your name written out the front
but they don't have posters around the
club going next week
david spade next week kevin neal and or
whatever you know what i mean they don't
have
that so people just
went to comedy because they wanted to go
see comedy and the club might have a
reputation for having the best acts
or what have you and another club might
be have a reputation for having worse
acts or maybe they pay less
or whatever you know but so so the fact
that
no one was sort of getting paid more
than anybody else and we were all sort
of in the same boat
it didn't breed jealousy or
competitiveness
like it does over here and also in
america there seems to be
britain there's so few tv opportunities
you know you might go on a panel show or
something like that but comics getting
offered sitcom deals isn't really a
thing
you know because there's not that many
sitcoms there's just not enough channels
to do that you know
and in america it's like that guy got a
development doing what
how the [ __ ] did this person get it you
know so
that i think breeds uh more jealousy and
maybe
less kindred spirits than the british
one
i think i still have more friends in
comedy in the uk than i do in england
in america but i i it's coming to say
that when i moved to america i was
already sort of established and
i was older and i sort of just keep to
myself to be honest i i i like uh
i like uh when i'm not doing comedy it's
just not think about comedy and when i
was younger all i did was think about
comedy and what do i do at home
jokes jokes jokes jokes and now i just
sort of
try not to watch anybody and and try to
keep to myself
and then try to try to be a good dad and
all that type of stuff and i think that
just comes with age
when did you first feel in say the uk
that you were successful and that that's
relative right so it could have been a
small win it could have been a big win
but when did you feel
holy [ __ ] like i think i'm on my way
this could be well
there's several different stages to that
now the first stage is
i didn't have a day job anymore so i
stopped working in the bars
and i you know i was working in pubs and
stuff when i first got there i started
working in bars and then comedy was my
full-time job and that was
that was maybe the best feeling i've had
of anything ever
i think that was the best one was when
that this is my job and you
you got to when you got to the airport
and you had to write down occupation in
the form and i got the right stand-up
comedian
yeah i felt i still i still [ __ ] get
a little buzz out of doing that man i
still
stand up comedian and um then
you know the next sort of step what
happened was in britain
in my opinion if you weren't doing the
annabra festival you weren't
really trying you know and the edinburgh
festival
unlike montreal or what have you
or some of the other ones around the
world where you're invited to these
festivals
you're not invited to edinburgh you just
decide if you want to do it
and then you go up there and do it and
if people show up
well that's good for you but it's a real
it's a real litmus test
on whether people like you or not
because you went from being in the clubs
to you're getting
reviewed by 15 or 20 publications
now some of these publications are just
pissy little student rags that are
around for the three weeks of the
festival and some of them are the
scotsman and the telegraph and big you
know independent and proper
newspapers and so you'd go up to
edinburgh
and so i did one edinburgh festival and
in a 50-seater and i saw i averaged 30
tickets a night and i thought that's
pretty good
and then the next year i went up and i i
had 120 seater
and i sold that out
and then then and then afterwards so
then
that my management put me into um little
community centers around the uk to just
do solo shows you know
and uh little 200 seat community
theaters in these small little villages
little towns and villages in between the
towns you know
uh what happened was so i was about to
my first tour and then
you know 2006 and i i got punched in the
head and this is before things went
viral or it was before really
youtube was what youtube was and then
this thing was on
everywhere with me getting punched in
the head yeah you mentioned manchester
earlier is manchester united comedy
story
is a manchester coney store and so this
little tour i was meant to be doing sold
out
and you know i've always said that you
know a lot of people go oh that was
lucky but it was but you
you still have to be able to back it up
you know because a lot of opportunities
happen to a lot of people it's whether
you whether you're
ready to pounce on it you know and so so
that was
that was sort of a a bigger moment you
know
and then going off every time you got to
a new festival and
you know i remember i remember feeling
really big the first time someone paid
for an airplane ticket for me
i thought that's something i'm traveling
and i went and did some gigs in asia and
then i went to montreal and
and i was like it was just an economy
but i remember thinking [ __ ] and i'm
seeing the world for
free and that seemed like a big deal to
me because
my growing up me parents my parents saw
the world
and they you know for two years they
traveled and i was always sort of
envious of that and thought
i'll never be able to do that i'll never
you know and then
when i got to do it and stay in nice
hotels that type of stuff that felt like
a real
real achievement you know and then
everything since then hasn't really felt
like
anything to be honest nothing american
success or anything's just sort of felt
like
i now i'm of the opinion that
it'll all go away one day it'll all end
or it won't be
what it is now or and you've got to be
happy without it
you know if you're not happy with it you
won't be happy without it so
that's why i'm saying the rise was
better than the thing now it's like
all right when's this going to end and
then
when you when you're younger you're like
the sky's the limit
and now it's like i don't need to go up
any higher
i've seen enough i've seen enough of the
sky
what keeps you going
these days right i would agree that the
sort of
chasing the summit is in a lot of ways
more fun
than getting up there and being like
jesus christ okay now what
well now it's more about
less about success and more about making
good work you know
do it like like it's also it's also
things now it's like so i'm doing a
multi-cam sitcom now
and if you asked me even a year ago if
i'd ever do a multicam sitcom i'd think
no one would ever
put me in a multi-cam sitcom and then
when i got asked
some of some of the fanbase were calling
me a sellout and all that type of stuff
because i'm doing a multi-cam
and it's like you know what [ __ ] you man
it's like i watched seinfeld i watch
friends i watch cheers i watch all these
things i love those shows
there's a rumor about these shows that
oh but they have a laugh track
they don't have a laugh track it's a
[ __ ] studio audience people are
actually laughing
that's real laughter you know it's but
it seemed to be a bit cheap or something
but you know
i i am i think now is
is uh challenging myself is is what you
want to do you know so i'm not
a good actor sometimes i get better at
it
the more i do it you know what i mean
i'd like to get good at acting i think
that would be a thing that would be
you know i would never have the audacity
to call myself an actor i say
stand-up comedian slash actor and i
always think i should take that bit off
the act a bit
yeah because that's not a real thing but
yeah
because i know i know real actors i've
i've got some friends who are proper
actors and uh they're a complete class
difference from what i can do every
every job like in legit i played myself
you know i'm gonna play myself in this
sitcom it's like
it's like i'm not really an actor
actress such as someone who just
reads the lines as myself
well let's talk about you mentioned
getting better at acting let's talk
about
comedy for a second and flashback to
edinburgh so for people who want a
picture edinboro is this
extremely picturesque town
you know it's a beautiful city it's
beautiful you've got the the coffee
shops
where jk rowling wrote the uh the
sorcerer's apprentice
you forgot i know she's from is she from
edinburgh there you go uh
she wrote she wrote a number of the
books there i think at the elephant room
and then
like beautiful fudge kind of looks like
hogwarts you can see all these buildings
uh what happens just since i don't know
anything about the festival
if it's not invite only what happens if
too many comics show up or is it just so
intimidating that that doesn't happen
and do you just kind of walk into town
like uh with a
a stick and a satchel over your shoulder
there's there's just unlimited rooms
there's just unlimited
they they go to the university they use
every single classroom they'll find any
like they'll find a closet and go this
is a four seat room
there's half of these rooms are complete
not a fire hazards
they shouldn't be allowed well and it's
and it's in the middle of summer and
people are sweltering there's people
fainting in your audience or something
and then there's the biggest room is a
thousand seats which is my cue and hall
but then they do things like
they put tents up so there's a lot of
like there's a lot of um
sort of uh park areas and they just
whack tents up everywhere and people
perform in these tents and what happens
is the these venues
will start operating at nine in the
morning and they'll be running at four
in the morning
right wow and and each each hour yeah
is is someone's act and so you know when
like my first show i got like an
11 o'clock p.m spot which isn't a great
spot you want that sort of
six to nine sort of area and then like
as you get more popular they go oh
you've got the eight o'clock spot and
you're like oh
the eight o'clock spot you know what i
mean so that like i heard something 2
000 shows are up at the festival
and it's not just it's not just stand-up
comedy stand-up comedy for whatever
reason is the bit that people
it's known for but it's an arts festival
so there's a lot of like there's a lot
of cool things like during the day
there's a lot of shows that you can see
that you can take your kids to something
some puppetry or
or some type of clowning type thing or a
lot of stand-up comics
who are more family friendly they might
do their adult show at night and they'll
do a kids show during the day
you know which is a cool thing and i
look i never could i was always
hungover and sleep until 5 pm and then
i'd
crawl out and do my show i used to gain
like 20 pounds
at that festival you know and then work
at all just beer weight just horrible
fat you know
anyway but uh uh it's it's for me
it's a it's a magical place it more than
any other festival
because it was just it was just
everybody up there was creative and
and it was people that wanted to do
their things and people
comics were were experimenting they
couldn't do in comedy clubs
there was things that i was doing that i
i did i did a story
that was 30 40 minutes long
um 40 minutes long about taking my
friend with muscular dystrophy to a
brothel
and the the thing about that is i'd
never done
a set in a comedy club that was more
than 20 minutes
so i i i couldn't have done that routine
if not for the edinburgh festival
even if i wanted to you know um
there was but the thing is i think the
average loss is 5 000 pounds
it's your own money and the promoters
are making money and there's posters
everywhere right and then you got to pay
for the posters then you got to pay for
people to flyer for you
all day or you got to fly for yourself
and so if you
break even on that festival if you come
out like going yeah
zero that's you really crushed it you
really crushed it
and so it's it's a gamble but the thing
is you get reviewers you get media
so there's things like what's her name
um fleabag um you know the
phoebe phoebe waller
phoebe waller she just wrote the last
james bond movie
and she had a team she
yeah she won an emmy for a tv show flea
bag
okay i'll try to find her we'll put it
in the show notes
anyway like like her show phoebe walter
bridge
is that the phoebe walla bridge right so
her show was just a show at the
edinburgh festival
that some bbc executives saw and
make it a tv show and then all of a
sudden
you got a tv show then she's got
american tv and now she's [ __ ]
writing james bond
and that magic doesn't happen out of a
comedy club it just doesn't
you know and so so you know like the
edinburgh festival gave us
stephen fry and hugh laurie you know
that they
won one of the first awards and all
these great sketch groups that you know
i don't think monty python ever did it
but maybe they
did i don't know well i'm a huge python
guy
you are yeah i had i had john cleese
came over my house for dinner and i was
just fanboying out the whole time and it
was the
[ __ ] best man it was the i'm friends
with his daughter
and they were gonna come and see one of
my shows they're going to come and see
one of my shows and then because
this is the early stages of quarantine
before everyone was quarantined but we
were canceling live things
it was like first week and so my show
was cancelled and he was going to come
and i said oh
just come over for dinner and then i
just was like [ __ ] john cleese is in
my house man
that was that was one of the great
thrills of my life if for people who
don't have and this is true i think of a
lot of
younger people who might be listening to
this from the us if they don't have
exposure to monty python where would you
suggest they start well
it's very easy at the moment because uh
i think netflix has all of it
yeah oh yeah i think the easiest
the most palatable thing to the case the
best movie is the life of brian
but maybe if you just want to have
something that's like easy palatable and
i think they think it's their worst film
i'd watch the meaning of life first
because it's small small sketches and
it's easy to watch
i'm not a big holy grail or jabberwocky
fan i
i like i like the life of brian but the
flying circus show
is as good as anything and all of those
are on
netflix and they're ready to watch you
know
all the sketches are good they're all
good it's just like
the the classic ones like the dead
parrot and all that type of stuff
they're not even the best ones they're
just the most
easy to quote i think yeah they're not
even the best ones
well let's talk about your brothel visit
with your friend with muscular dystrophy
all right so edinburgh festival it's a
big opera it's a big it's a big
opportunity
how do you work on that material like
what did you do to get that ready
that's a big set well that that routine
pretty much has the story there's that
you have stories that are partly true
and stories that you embellish and
stories that you add on things and
you know but that story is very very
close to 100 true
very close and um
what happened there was i had my friend
his brother wanted to get a blow job
and we sorted it out and then and then
you know
this the story happened and i remember
when that happened
i was actually at the melbourne
melbourne comedy festival which i've
only done once
i went into the bar the comedian's bar
in melbourne
and i literally walked in i saw a couple
of friends of mine and i said have i got
a story for you
and i remember i started telling it by
the time i was halfway through this
story there was maybe
11 people standing around in this bar
and people saying turn the music down
right and i was talking about this
brothel visit and i remember thinking
wow this is keeping comedians attention
you know and i think i probably
i probably told that story um
to like in pubs and to friends for about
a year
and before it just became it is the
standard bit of a comedy for me
and then from that the tv show legit
is from you know the tv my tv my at an
fx tv show
which was completely based on that story
and it was a one-o that was just the
pilot episode was taking someone to a
brother like with muscular dystrophy to
a brothel
and then when we did the show afterwards
we did another 26 episodes
and the thing that was weird was then
you have a character with muscular
dystrophy that you have to write
into each episode and i thought god i
only really need this guy for one
but then that became that became the
sweetness of the show that became the
sweet thing
but but it was hard sometimes you'd
write a funny scene or something funny
would happen in your life
and you think oh i got to put that in
the show and then you go
and i have to work in a guy in a
wheelchair
[Laughter]
how do you and i apologize i'm not a
comics
i don't even know proper vocabulary we
have i think
we have some mutual friends like uh
whitney cummings and
uh brian cowan and these guys who will
have much more pointed questions but
for lack of a better way to ask how do
you workshop
some of your more uh
i was gonna say intricate but just
longer pieces for instance
and i know you get asked about this all
the time but if we look at
the gun control or gun related
pieces that you've done i mean those are
like long theatrical
pieces well the gun can go i have an
interesting story on how i wrote gun
control
that routine that's probably i think
that probably is the routine i'm most
proud about i think it's the most
sort of thought-provoking or original or
whatever thing that i
i did was that gun control routine that
i think was most memorable
um and sadly the routine always gets new
legs after
there's a shooting or something like
that so it's not the way you want to
get known you know but um
that routine now now i have to stipulate
when i say this
okay with americans i understand that
many of you like guns
and i'm not anti-you i don't think
you're wrong i i
j well i do think you're wrong but but i
grew up in a society without guns and i
have had a different life experience
from you um and so this is just my point
of view it doesn't mean that my point of
view is right and your point of view is
wrong
it's just this is this is my way of
thinking on the matter
um so i have a guy and i'm happy to call
this man a friend
um who does not agree with me in any way
and this guy's a more republican than
i'm i'm more moderate i think people
think i'm a big lefty but i'm
a bit more moderate than i think people
would realize but
and it's john ratzenberg from cheers
no no kidding cliff cliff clavin from
cheers
and cliff clavin was on my tv show legit
and uh i was i was with him when sandy
hook happened
and uh we were on set and uh
he said to me yeah jimmy yeah if only
these teachers had guns we wouldn't have
these problems
and i went you're [ __ ] kidding you
want teachers to have guns
and we argued and debated for a few days
on this matter you know it was never
mean or nasty or anything like that it
was just
you know i couldn't believe that
americans thought this way about guns i
don't worry
before that i already i always knew you
liked guns
but when i heard these arguments and i
was saying to other people do you i
think
this guy at work you wouldn't believe
what he said it's [ __ ] crazy and then
i started finding out
that other people who were friends of
mine agreed with him as well
and then other bit and i thought oh man
maybe i'm not in the minority but this
is a very common belief they all have
and so then you start thinking maybe i'm
wrong or maybe i'm whatever and so
i just wanted to give not a scientific
or a statistic based
argument on the guns i just wanted to
give
my point of view and just looking at it
rationally
type of argument you know so that
routine was written through arguments
with other people it was just
conversations with other people
it wasn't written by it wasn't written
by me going oh and i wonder what the
statistic is on this and i wonder what
that is
and reading and researching it was me
just arguing with friends
until i got all my arguments down and i
was like all right this is what i'm
coming in with this is what i'm coming
in with and very often
stand-up comedy is just you having a
one-sided argument
and uh no i'm being able to respond
which is a one
which is a wonderful thing they all
respond in the end they all write
something at the end on the internet and
try to get you
or they come up to you but and in that
moment on stage
your argument is gospel and no one can
say any different
doesn't mean it doesn't mean it's right
doesn't mean it's right and as you're
having these arguments
are you refining all this in your head
just catching it in a net or
you do you have a little black book you
pull out of your pocket you know
something comes up how do you capture
i i don't write jokes down and i really
should because
i lose track of punch lines and stuff
like that and
other lines can seep in you can you know
you can you can get i should write
things down but i never [ __ ] write
things down
i do most of me writing on stage you
have a kernel of a thought
and you wait till you're doing it doing
a gig where you're really cooking
and the audience really likes you and
you think i can get away with anything
right now
and then you do your bit and if it
doesn't work you go straight back into a
bit that's
you know really well it's very solid and
so so that's how i do it on stage and
a lot of people in la they'll invite you
to do a gig
and they'll say um they'll say
uh hey come down to my room and try out
it's a good place to try out new stuff
and it's like are you [ __ ] out of
your mind i'm gonna come down to 10
minutes and try out new stuff i i
i in la where someone important might be
i i wedged i wedged the joke in in
kansas in
my two-hour show in the middle of you
know when you're doing two hours on
stage i try to work in two new minutes
each time three new minutes and then
that three minutes becomes five minutes
and then at the end of the year you've
got a new show
that's why i always find it weird that
you expected to have a new tour
written when really these tours are
if you see me a year and a half apart
it'll be a new show
but if you see me even if it's a
different tour and it's a month apart
it's not going to be that much different
because everything's just evolving and
moving and turning
and then the specials come out and once
the special comes out you never say
those jokes again
and when and when you try out this new
two or three minutes if it really
works or it partially works do you just
make a mental note do you go back and
watch the video or listen to tape
yeah i don't tape them either i i
normally i'm normally so focused on
those two three minutes that i know that
you know i know i know what i'm going to
do
but the the two or three minutes
sometimes
that works better than the stuff that's
killer even though it's not as good a
joke because
for whatever reason the audience can see
that you're excited by that joke and
they can see the sparkle behind
your eye and there's that little bit of
magic that happens because you're so
excited and
you can't fake that and you can't act
excited about a joke you've told a
hundred times you can't you can perform
it well
you can perform it really well you can
put everything into it and make it great
but you can never have that magic where
you're grinning through it because
you're like oh this is so good you know
what i mean and so
so because because doing a new bit of
stand-up that's the most enjoyable bit
of the whole show for the for
the for the performer at least it is for
me life of brian
so let's let's come back to that if you
don't mind what is it
about life of brian that makes it so
good in your mind
well it's the perfect movie the thing
about it is there's plenty of quotable
sort of sketches in there and stuff like
that um
it's mocking religion which i love
but it's but it's but it's also not
mocking religion
in a direct way it's like the christians
can get upset and go this is sacrilege
and that type of stuff no
they don't tease jesus at all you know
what i mean they have the beginning the
meek
they will inherit this and inherit that
but they don't really get into jesus
we're talking about brian if you want to
say that this is about jesus that's your
[ __ ] problem you know there's a lot
of people going around
acting like they were prophets who got
crucified back in the day
and if you want to say that we can't
talk about them that seems a bit
ridiculous so it's a lovely little
loophole
where you can poke fun at people and
still you know and also that stuff about
the
what did the romans ever do for us the
aqueduct of this
that it's just it's very very funny
are there any other comics who were
really formative for you or people you
have uh formative or people you've
looked at and just
said to yourself i don't know how they
do what they do right because
i guess those are two kind of two
separate things i suppose
george carlin um when i started watching
him i thought that was
that that he was pretty amazing and i
you know i i i get a little bit carl and
esque on a joke here and there and i got
to watch myself because i i i'd love to
have been that man you know
he seems like the perfect comedian to me
um
i i would say um there was a guy called
anthony
morgan as well when i was growing up in
australia who was
very influential on me growing up
and i don't know what he is does these
days and i haven't seen him since but
um but he he was he was a big deal for
me and eddie murphy's delirious was a
pivotal moment in my childhood was
the first time i saw someone who was an
australian doing stand-up comedy
gotta understand in australia we only
had four tv channels we had no
comedy specials i didn't know richard
pryor was a comedian i thought he was an
actor
right we had no stand-up specials we had
no hbo that didn't exist
or we we didn't even have american tv we
didn't have i couldn't see
who was doing well on carson that didn't
exist
those clips never got to us you know we
had our own late night shows with our
own
comics on them and you'd see them for a
few minutes and that was all you really
saw
of them and then delirious was the first
cinematic release
stand-up special so it was in the video
store
and i remember watching it and i
couldn't get over that this guy was
doing stand-up comedy for an hour
that blew my mind i thought that
stand-up comedy was only in a medium
of five minutes that's what everyone did
then you couldn't watch someone
afterwards and i remember
like i wasn't uh good looking i wasn't
good at sports i wasn't anything you
know that
was deemed to be cool you know i
couldn't
play on a guitar i couldn't you know and
just to see
someone who was doing something that i
believed i had the innate talent to be
able to do
and he was cool you know what i mean i
never said
like because comedy before that before
eddie murphy for me
i didn't it was we're goofy we're goofy
people
and i still to this day don't
particularly care if so my mother always
used to go
their laugh those kids at school are
laughing at you not with you and i i
just
didn't care as long as i was getting the
last because i still knew
i was doing it to get laughs it didn't
matter to me where they came from
and so just to see someone who was cool
and he was
you know like let's be honest i wear a
[ __ ] leather jacket on all my
specials because [ __ ] eddie murphy
all those leather jumpsuits there's one
of my specials i wear without a t-shirt
i just wanted to just
once once i have a leather and i've
never done that in my personal life or
anything
just before i walked out on stage i went
[ __ ] it i'm taking the t-shirt off
i'm gonna be like eddie murphy and just
just just wear a
leather jacket on bare skin i [ __ ]
that jacket stinks to this day
do you think you'll still be in la or
is is la home base for you in 10 years
time
la's home and um
la's home and i don't believe
that uh you know i got a kid and
i would like to have another child um
sometimes so
i think when you have children
i think that's your your moving's done
you know what i mean i think maybe i
could retire in hawaii or something like
that depending if my kid
[ __ ] goes off and works in new york
or whatever what's the point of me
staying in la
you know maybe i could go off to santa
barbara and buy a place and
go for [ __ ] walks or whatever the
[ __ ] people do when they're old but
you know you could it could be you could
be in a lot worse places than la
there's nothing wrong with it yeah i i i
really get a bit home proud of
la and i don't like when people bag on
it and people
just go oh la oh you must hate it there
and they're like oh the traffic the
traffic where i live doesn't have
traffic because your place is [ __ ]
la's got traffic la's got traffic
because people want to [ __ ] live here
that's why there's traffic
because people want to be here and it's
good and the food's good and the women
are pretty and [ __ ] you know what i mean
like what would you
mean you want to [ __ ] the restaurants
are nice like there's there's
places other places that are nice as
well but there's just what my argument
is there's nothing wrong with la
well la is also i mean this took me a
while to figure out
uh and obviously there are many people
who spent more time there but i
lived in northern california for almost
20 years and spent a lot of time in
southern california is that la
to me strikes me like as if it's a dozen
different cities
all within the umbrella of la right so
you can really
kind of pick your pocket depending on
where you want to be and the
personalities are very different
yeah i agree with that as well it's like
it's like when i moved to la
all i knew of la was two things there
was the hollywood
which was the ritzy looking lights and
that type of stuff
and then there was compton and they're
the only two things
that i had seen on tv you know what i
mean
and so i i used to think i used to
believe
i couldn't walk the streets in la
because a blood or a [ __ ] would
come and shoot me or you know what i
mean like there'd be a drive-by or
something it's [ __ ]
or i'd be in beverly hills and it would
just be girls with long legs with dogs
in handbags and i thought that was all
there was
and it turns out it turns out there's
also the valley
what do you think uh and uh
and i won't keep you too much longer but
uh and we're definitely going to talk
about the podcast but
what has helped you to have longevity
in comedy uh because it seems like you
have some longevity
yeah i think it's producing um
a lot of uh specials i think bringing
out the specials constantly sort of keep
you going the specials never
i never like do a special and then it's
like wow you're more popular now or
anything like that but it just keeps
your fan base going and
i think you gotta you gotta give you
gotta give a product
you know you you've got to keep touring
you've got to you know
if you if you you keep your eye off the
ball then i'm not a big believer in that
i'm in competition with anybody
else i just think if i just keep on
producing good quality stuff i'll always
have
a fan base whether it be small or large
or whatever there'll be somebody
somewhere that wants to
pay to watch me tell jokes you know so
but
as i said if if it all ends tomorrow and
i i
i just become like an old fellow who
sits around
showing my kid pictures like ah one time
i played the tennis arena in melbourne
you know what i mean like
i i think i'm all right with that too i
don't know i don't i don't know the
secret to
being a successful comic is like i
really couldn't tell you
if i could tell you i'd go manage
comedians and stop doing it myself
when you think back to the filling in of
the customs form
with stand-up comedian and the high that
that gave you when you first did it
not that it would be the same magnitude
of high it could be but like what
what gives you that type of high now
or in the last handful of years or what
are you hoping to do that would
give you that type of that type of hair
i think if i was
in a dramatic movie that would be
something that's something
that right now i can't foresee ever
happening so that would be one
thing that would surprise me if that
happened because i've
there's that's not on the horizon no
one's ever asked or
asked if i'm interested or anything like
that so if that happened that would be
something that would shock me if that
happened and
you know i don't i don't suspect it will
happen but if that happened it would
shock me but
you know it might sound corny the the
thing i get the most joy out of is
probably being a dad i'm i really like
being a dad
i i think i think
i'm more proud of of when i do that well
than when i do comedy well
what what do you how do you know when
you're being a good dad
that's the thing man that's the thing
you don't know you keep
yeah you know it's it's it's i know i
know my son really loves me
and that's cool yeah i know that and
then you do
things where just little things you know
you teach some a kid to ride a bike and
you're like
yeah i did it because you know as a
parent i
i i don't know how to like like my son's
still having problems doing his
shoelaces
and i feel like i've let him down a bit
there he's getting a bit old
he's he's getting a bit old and he
should be able to do it and i feel like
hey i dropped the ball i dropped the
ball on that one
[Music]
is he 18 19 i mean how's he no he's he's
seven and he's seven
okay all right just checking he's seven
but i
i've read that he should have been able
to do it by the time he was six
and he's hopeless at it you know he
gives it a go and then i go
but because i keep buying him [ __ ]
shoes with velcro on him you know what i
mean
so i feel like that's lazy parenting
where i've stuffed up a little bit you
know
but uh i think uh
you know you take them on a good holiday
or you you you work hard and you get
them into a good school and you do all
those type of things
and i feel like all right because
otherwise what's all this for
if you're not going to give the next
generation a better life than you had
yeah yeah thinking about kids
for the first time really for me in the
last 18 months or so
so it's um i've i have a newfound
interest in talking to people who are
parents
but i don't want to belabor that i don't
want to turn this into a therapy session
too quickly
so let's talk about the uh the new
podcast i don't know about that
why why this show why well
well i i think and and now it no offense
to you i think there's enough
shows where people are interviewing
people
you know i mean i agree i agree i agree
with that
yeah yeah and and so so and i you know
you talk about
what there definitely is there's far too
many comedians
interviewing comedians like it seems
like a very weird thing
now that we all go on each other's
podcasts and we talk about how we get
started and how to write a joke and what
type of stuff
and then i i just sort of i thought like
like
the well it was like how do things work
or the more you know and all those type
of podcasts where they
talk about stuff those are the ones that
i sort of was interested in where i was
like
i i started listening to less comedy
podcasts and more podcasts where i could
learn something and then those
those um crime ones everyone likes those
so much because they they have
some thing they learn about now this
also goes back to my father
is a very difficult man to argue with
because if you prove him wrong
and like he'll say oh this happened that
happened and you're bloody this and that
and then you go well dad that's not
actually true you know
like because in 1948 the government did
blah blah blah you say that
and you give him facts and then my
father just goes well i don't know about
that
and that's that's not conceding that's
just going oh
maybe you're right i doubt it you know
what i mean
so i thought well what the podcast is is
what will happen is
each podcast will have a specialist on
somebody who knows
a lot about a subject whether they've
written a book or they've done a ted
talk on it or whatever the [ __ ]
and they'll come on and i won't know who
they are
or what they do and then they have to
say that
their topic of expertise and then i will
say
everything that i think i know about
that thing right
because you remember before the internet
when you had a guy in a bar
who you used to think was the smartest
person ever and then the internet came
out and
you could just google things and turned
out he was completely full of [ __ ]
all right i'm gonna be that guy right
and then at the end the guy the person
the specialist will tell me
uh what i got right what i got wrong
um what misinformation i had
uh what is a common uh bit of
misinformation on the thing
and then we'll all learn together about
this specialist topics and we'll keep it
funny and we'll keep it light and then
at the end of the thing you'll know
about a topic
i love it what are some of the topics on
the on the slab
we've record well i see i don't know i
don't know that's right that's right so
what have you recorded so far just to if
you can give people a sort of a preview
or maybe you don't want to um
i can i think i can queen name a couple
alex or yeah
we did uh we did the war on drugs and
we've done earthquakes we've done like
four or five of these but that's a
couple we did earthquakes in the war and
drugs
[Laughter]
[Music]
and now i know [ __ ] loads about
earthquakes and the war on drugs i know
a lot of stuff now
but before i did i didn't know much well
i love the format i mean i i do
i do agree with you i think there's a
over abundance of
interview style formats and who knows i
may end up
looking at the photos reminiscing on the
old days and
i'd be okay with that too uh at some
point if that if i if i
i if you're one of the bigger ones tim i
think you'll be just fine
yeah i think it'll be fine but you know
there might be a time to take old yeller
behind the shed and
put him put him to rest uh but uh
well i i love your comedy
i think you're a smart guy it's very
very thought provoking as i mentioned at
the very beginning
the new podcast is i don't know about
that which is debuting tuesday
may 5th and uh i'm sure people can find
more about it on jim jeffries.com you
can be found on twitter instagram
at jim jeffries is there anything else
you'd like to share or anywhere else
that people can no man
no no just uh subscribe to the new
podcast i have
all my gigs are cancelled because i have
no shows to promote but uh
hopefully after this quarantine's all
over i'll be coming to a city near you
thanks for having me tim oh my pleasure
and i will
uh for everybody listening link to i
don't know about that
link to some of the the episodes
we mentioned the manchester head
punching incident
a couple of the clips and bits uh as
well as tv shows everything in the show
notes
as usual at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast
and uh jim thank you so much for the
time i really appreciate it i appreciate
it mate thank you bye-bye
and to everybody listening until next
time thanks for tuning in
you